One solution to tracking the various paths that light can take to reach the eye
is to shoot a lot more rays per pixel and bounce them around in hopes of
finding light sources. This is called path tracing. It can be very noisy to
start with but can give correct results with enough time. This is a real-time
demo by Evan Wallace in WebGL, one I recommend you try yourself. Notice the
color bleeding effect of light bouncing off the walls onto the spheres. You can
also make objects have glossy reflections instead of the sharp ones we see with
classical ray tracing. This demo uses what is called progressive rendering,
shooting more and more rays for each pixel and blending in the results. The
longer you wait, the better the image gets. You can even use path tracing to
render scenes form MineCraft. Here's one I made using the free chunky path
tracer, giving a beam of light effect down the scene. A basic pure path tracer
is pretty straightforward to write. You generally shoot more rays in sensible
directions and sum up the light contributions found. Where all the time gets
burned is that you're shooting tens of thousands of rays per pixel or more.
This scene took about 16 hours with 12 CPU threads and it was still a bit noisy
at that point. I should mention there are many other algorithms such as photon
mapping and bidirectional path tracing that work to get the best of both
worlds. The general idea is to send light out from emitters using rays
depositing radiance wherever the rays reach. The scene is then retraced from
the camera's view and the emitted light is gathered. Algorithms such as path
tracing can give unparalleled realism, given enough time. Set up properly, a
rendering can be a true simulation of how light percolates through a scene. Not
just an artistic approximation. I used to work on a global illumination system
back in the 80s and 90s. Even back then we knew that path tracing could, given
enough computer cycles, get the right answer. The running joke was that we were
mostly just biding our time, coming up with optimizations for other algorithms
while wait the 50 years needed for computers to get powerful enough to shoot
10,000 rays per pixel to get the right answer. Nowadays I think you probably
need more like 100,000 or a million rays per pixel, but by my watch, I just
need to wait another quarter century for rendering to be over, and then the
singularity comes anyway, assuming people don't put more objects in their
scenes.